another issue that we've got to be
careful with here when we talk about
capitalism and individualism is what it
does to the family
story here
about a fictosexual
have you heard of fictosexuals
i had not now i have fictosexual man
who married a 16 year old hologram
can't communicate with her after
software support was eliminated
star-crossed
digital lovers here uh this is a man
a 38 year old japanese man who wed a
holographic image of a 16 year old blue
haired anime character so it's a it's
not that the it's not that the
technology is 16 years old but that the
character depicted is 16 years old
the character's name is hatsune miku
and
he fell in love with this character
he apparently had a difficult social
life he was bullied at work he was
ostracized and so he is now pretending
to be married to this
[Applause]
digital character but it's it's really
their starcrust lovers because the the
company stopped updating the software so
now he can no longer even pretend to
interact with the hologram obviously
this guy's got a lot of problems uh he
should he should receive some help and
his co-workers who were bullying him
should be nicer to him and he should be
brought into real
community
uh
this sort of thing should not be
encouraged or even really
permitted
the
extremes of individualism the extremes
of do whatever you want as long as it
doesn't hurt me
uh that that has no place in a
conservative political philosophy it has
no place in
japan or our country for that matter we
we live in a society we have a
responsibility toward one another
this fictosexual story is not just some
weird tabloid quirk it's where society
is headed
because what what lies at the bottom of
this is that
reality
doesn't really matter anymore that's the
basis of this reality doesn't really
matter physical reality spiritual
reality we can now move into digital
react virtual reality the metaverse what
we can we can go and deny the realities
of sex we can pretend to be the opposite
sex if we want it if we're living in the
metaverse it doesn't matter because our
bodies don't really play a role in
virtual reality we can deny
our community we can just fall in love
with a computer
and end up in a
solipsistic hell
we can fall in love with a computer and
just end up in our own delusions and our
own fantasies and this is encouraged by
technology and by an extremely
individualist society and economy and
politics and that's not good that's not
going to make anybody happy this guy is
the fictosexual is not happy i bet he's
very lonely and very sad and he thinks
that pretending to be married to a
computer is making him happier and is
providing a sort of band-aid over the
pain but it's not making anything better
it's actually only making the condition
worse
and we've got to speak
honestly about that that's what that's
what a lot of this
abortion debate is over
even the the kind of basic conservative
legal argument hey look if we overrule
roe v wade you can still get abortions
in
in new york you can still get abortions
in california
that's fine that's fine by me but it's
not fine it's not fine okay there
certain things are just true and other
and certain things are false certain
things are good and certain things are
bad and certain things shouldn't be
tolerated anywhere and we actually do
have the right to make that claim
we have the right
to tell our fellow americans to some
degree how to live that's not
authoritarian that's not fascistic it's
not totalitarian it's called living in a
society
it's called
being a citizen that's that's what that
is and americans once understood that
and we have become alienated from that
not only because of the radical left not
only because of marxism but also because
of the the disorders and perversions of
a kind of capitalism too and if we want
to preserve our traditional system of
free enterprise and private property and
the american way of life we need to be
honest about that and we need to correct
that sort of thing
speaking of romance speaking of virtual
digital romance
skeet davidson
mr pete
skeet davidson
that
guy from saturday night live who is
destroying kanye west's marriage to kim
kardashian
pete davidson has has taken his
predations to a new level
he has gotten the initials of kanye
west's children
tattooed on his neck
this is extremely creepy and weird
behavior
he was texting kanye he said hey man i
want us all to get along i just want to
be friends with your kids and kanye said
you're never going near my kids
absolutely under no circumstances weirdo
get out of here and
you can tell a major difference between
the left and the right
based on where they fall on the kanye
story i think a lot of people are just
going to ignore the kanye story because
the kardashians are an absolute plague
on american culture that's but
the kardashians are very popular kanye
west is probably the most popular
entertainer in the world even skeet
davidson is fairly popular and so
these people have our attention
the conservatives tend to be team kanye
and and the libs tend to be team skeet
and kim kardashian
this is not only because kanye west put
on the maga hat like donald trump
i think it actually has nothing to do
with it the reason is because kanye west
very publicly wants to save his marriage
and keep his family together and raise
his children
and kim kardashian does an interview in
vogue magazine and says my 40s are just
going to be about me enough of other
people enough of living my life for
other people like you know my kids and
my family and my responsibilities toward
my community and my god no no i'm just
gonna do it for me me me me and i'm
gonna date this meth-head looking
saturday night live comedian who gets my
kids names tattooed on his necks like a
total creep
that's what i'm gonna do me me me and
the same thing with skeet who's going in
and taking another man's wife which is
just wrong
and
the what the libs argue is well kim
kardashian wasn't happy in her marriage
and look there's no evidence that kanye
west was abusive in any way that he was
some kind of ogre but you know he's a
weird guy he's eccentric i think
everyone knew that going in
and so kim should just be able to leave
whenever she wants because the left has
absolutely no respect for marriage and
has been trying to destroy it for a long
time because getting back to our earlier
discussion about hyper individualism
the left and some portions of the right
actually agree
on a fundamental political issue they
think that the basic unit of society is
the individual the left says it's just
the individual and we have to collect
them all together into the collective
and the and the misguided part of the
right says the fundamental unit of
society is the individual and we got to
keep them individuals those are two
sides of the same coin
that's why both of those ideologies as
they advance seem to go in the same
direction whereas the actual alternative
is that the basic unit of society is not
the individual to be collectivized or
otherwise the basic unit of society is
the family
and the family provides a real bulwark
against the predations of the radicals
who want to upend our entire culture
the family is
sacred you want to talk about something
that's actually sacred
it's the it's the family the left says
it's sacred to destroy the family
whether through legislation or through
baby sacrifice or anything else the
right says no to preserve the family
is sacred
so what do we do about this
what do we do about a culture in which
kids are are
why
across the country are the victims of
things like divorce of mommy bringing
creepy boyfriends like skeet davidson
around of of
tumultuous sorts of relationships and
upbringing the answer is
make it a little harder to get divorced
i'm not even saying make it illegal to
get divorced but make it a little harder
to get divorced
until about half a century ago
you had to provide a reason to get
divorced
when you enter into a marriage you're
signing a contract and it's not just any
kind of contract it's not like you're
just putting together an accounting firm
you're getting together and saying
i am making a vow to create a
fundamental political unit here with
babies with responsibilities
so it's going to be hard to get out of
it
now for the last half century
we've had something called no fault
divorce that's been a disaster for
everyone for kids for husbands for wives
for everyone after a wife gets a few
wrinkles around her eyes the husband can
just leave her now with without having
to really do anything at all
without having to prove cause he can go
and shut up his secretary
or the in this case the wife when she
gets sick of her husband's
eccentricities can just leave and take
the kids and expose the kids to some
creep like pete davidson
kanye has nothing that he can do about
it that's not good it's not good
for anybody
and it gives us a society in which the
skeet davidsons of the world can go in
and screw up all of our families don't
do it don't let that weirdo do it man
earl an earlier
american cult an earlier and saner
american culture would not have let
skeet davidson around its kids
did you like that clip cool
ring the bell please subscribe get the
notifications don't miss a single second
of a video
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you